when white nationalists say they hate
Muslims Latinos refugees and queer folks
their hate list often includes another
minority group Jews The Tree of Life
synagogue massacre in Pittsburgh which
left 11 worshippers dead reminded
Americans that hatred of Jews is not
simply a problem of the past or only one
in Europe anti-semitism or hatred of
Jews actually has a long and often
violent history in the u.s. it's also
frequently been used by white
nationalists and other right-wingers to
rally support against social and
progressive change once again rising to
remove Jews from Jews are infections
users stain on their threat to light
society and his statements on social
media the Pittsburgh synagogue killer
connected his hatred of Jews with his
hatred for Muslims and refugees so where
exactly does all this hate come from
American anti-semitism doesn't exist in
a vacuum and actually find its way to
the u.s. from Europe where Jews have
been persecuted for centuries Jews along
with Muslims were deemed a threat by
politically powerful churches and
persecuted by authoritarian rulers
looking for scapegoats on which to blame
social and economic problems but in
America virulent anti-semitism didn't
really take off until three million
Eastern European Jews emigrated here in
the early 20th century this migration
also happened is part of a much larger
wave of migration of some twenty million
people from eastern and southern Europe
to the America and so Jews were part of
that too just looking for economic
opportunity political Liberty and
religious freedom and so on many Jews
were escaping pogroms anti-jewish
massacres stoked by the monarchies of
Eastern Europe often as a diversion from
challenges to their own power there was
massive pogroms that took place in the
1890s there was one in 1901 1903 and
then with the 1905 attempt at a
revolution in Russia Jews had invested
themselves very fully nearly one-third
of those arrested in the opening days of
that violence
we're Jews like other immigrants at the
time Jewish immigrants face xenophobic
racist and anti-semitic hostility both
in their neighborhoods and in the u.s.
press and so you began to see and
systematic images of Jews as capitalists
so you have pictures of Jews and top
hats carrying bags of money anti-semitic
incidents were frequent during this era
including the lynching of Leo Frank by a
mob in Marietta Georgia
a violent tactic commonly used to
terrorize African Americans in the u.s.
south he had come from the north to
manage a pencil factory a young white
girl was found murdered and sexually
assaulted in the factory and he was
blamed with the thinnest bits of
evidence he was tried and convicted and
while his sentence was being appealed a
mob broke him out of prison dragged him
to Marietta and hanged him but
anti-semitism during this era went far
beyond what happened to Leo Frank
remember the Jewish participation and
Russian revolutions mentioned earlier
Jewish involvement in these uprisings
against the tyranny of Russian monarchs
spurred a new theme in right-wing
propaganda that Jewish revolutionaries
were conspiring with Jewish bankers to
take over the world
[Music]
accusations that Jewish revolutionaries
and bankers were behind movements for
social change became a rallying cry for
white nationalists to suppress campaigns
for workers rights and black civil
rights you have figures like Rosa
Luxemburg and Trotsky who are very
active in left waving communist
governments movements and so you begin
to see images of Jews as sort of the you
know the Bob throwing radical so you
have these contradictory images that
exist
tamed up which brings us the father
Coughlin a Catholic priest who in the
1930s was notorious for railing against
Jewish bankers in many of his radio
addresses something that white
nationalists and the alt-right continued
to peddle Coughlin's vehement opposition
to communism had overt anti-semitic
tones and was a part of his conspiracy
theories about a Jewish takeover of the
world and today Jews are being accused
of doing the same thing as being part of
the international global conspiracy
through organizations such as the United
Nations and international human rights
organizations white nationalist
sentiments had prompted the US
government in the 1920s to adopt
immigration quotas that sharply limited
Jewish and Italian immigration as a
result the u.s. denied entry to Jewish
refugees fleeing Nazi Germany and the
Holocaust Jewish immigrants in
particular were accused of being
conspirators against American democracy
and white homogeneity sound familiar
that's very much the same rhetoric that
we hear against refugees from Syria
today who were escaping religious
persecution this is the same rhetoric
that our President Trump is using right
now against migrants who are coming up
from Central America and hoping to find
sanctuary in the United States and the
younger generation of Jewish Americans
have become more vocal about calling out
attacks on marginalized communities
Rachael Goldstein of if not now a Jewish
activist group which opposes Israel's
occupation of the West Bank in Gaza is
calling for further solidarity between
minority communities when there's
anti-semitism when there are
anti-semitic attacks that's not just an
attack on Jews it's really attack on all
communities that are marginalized in the
decades since the Holocaust however the
white American mainstream has largely
integrated Jewish Americans a Pew study
from 2017 found that more than
of Americans rated Jews very warmly
higher than any other religious group
I've been really fortunate to grow up
without experiencing a ton of
anti-semitism especially not it's in its
most vicious form but I know that my
grandparents experienced things that
were much different than what I am even
my parents and to be a fourth generation
American Jew is a really different
experience all of this violence is
interconnected and I have to say as a
scholar of Jewish history and someone
who's part of the Jewish community it
seems incumbent upon Jewish Americans to
recognize that our fate is bound up with
the fate of other oppressed people in
America meanwhile the recent rise of
white nationalists and alt-right groups
has seen them unafraid to espouse
bigoted views towards Muslims Latinos
African Americans the LGBT community and
Jews before and after Pittsburgh
activists and many of these targeted
communities have called for a united
response here is Palestinian American
activist Linda Sarsour addressing Jewish
Americans in front of the White House at
a vigil for the victims in Pittsburgh
I'm here today with my Arab American and
Muslim family who came out here to send
a very loud and clear message to all of
you that we love you we stand with you
we are willing to risk everything so
that you too can have a right to
practice your religion freely in these
United States of America and remember
what happened at Charlottesville
this now famous moment was actually an
echo of a traditional white nationalist
rallying cry suggesting Jewish bankers
and Bolsheviks are behind people of
color struggling for social justice and
at this time with the political climate
that we're in right now with the
rhetoric that Donald Trump is sharing
with his base it has sort of allowed for
anti-semitism to come up to the surface
to make it more acceptable for white
nationalists to explicitly say things
like Jews will not replace us the
alt-right and white nationalists
consistently use terminology that can
only be described as not-so-subtle
attacks on Jews so the term globalist
that's being widely used today to attack
George Soros and other Jews is another
variant of the term internationalists
which was used in anti-semitic documents
the Jewish billionaire and
philanthropist George Soros is today's
incarnation of the Jew that white
nationalists love to hate for decades
he's funded the progressive causes and
groups that nationalists in both Eastern
Europe and in the United States cannot
stand and seek to discredit often as
foreign menaces this belief that there
are wealthy Jews who are controlling
world events with a goal to destabilize
Western countries Trump is not only
sounding an anti-semitic dog whistle to
cue other people he's making
straight-out anti-semitic arguments
himself no president Trump has come
under heavy criticism for his response
to Pittsburgh and Charlottesville he's
been accused of fanning the flames by
targeting specific groups through racist
policies and rhetoric he has opened the
door and given legitimacy to a group of
people that have been sidelined and
marginalized and he has just removed the
rock under which they had crawled and
given them free rein to engage in their
activities Robert Bowers the killer a
tree of life synagogue had said online
that he was targeting Jews because they
were helping invaders that kill our
people and named a Jewish charity
helping to resettle Muslim refugees in
America unsurprisingly he had also
ranted about the caravan of asylum
seekers from Central America so how our
American Jewish community is responding
to attacks by the white nationalist
right
well for some it's about recognizing the
connection between anti-semitism and
other forms of bigotry I am a young
American Jew who hasn't had to
experience quite the amount of pain that
some of the older folks in the American
Jewish community have so as a young
person I see it as a very clear path
forward that our future is bound in the
future of others and the future of other
people who are being targeted by white
nationalism Jews need to make I think a
decision I think we're at a crossroads
in some ways about how we're going to
approach this are going to reassert our
place within a white society align
ourselves with the state to align
ourselves with Authority are we going to
see that our fates are linked to that of
other oppressed peoples in the culture
[Music]